So, we're in the car and we are headed to our first destination which is Bielefeld.
We are on a week-long journey around Germany this week...
...because we found five, I think, four to seven vans...
...that we really like all throughout Germany,...
...and we decided to rent a car and go do a tour, and see them all.
And so they're mainly from eBay, so who knows what the quality of these sellers are gonna be like...
...but hopefully they're nice people...
...and with lovely vans that actually start.
Yeah. That's basically the update as of now.
That's about it. We're really excited.
Being in the car is so fun already, we're just in this hilarious Mini Cooper.
It's the first time either of us have ever rented a car on our own,...
...and we're in this little Mini.
It's really small but it's really fun to be in a car,...
...and to be on our own adventure.
We've only traveled through Germany in like FlixBus or like a bus.
And it's really different to be on your own.
You can stop whenever, and yeah, it just feels nice.
Control the radio.
I think we're really gonna like van life.
I agree.
See you later.